- Hey, babe.
- Hi.
- Um,
I made a really big decision
without consulting you.
I went by a puppy rescue
stand on University Avenue.
I had to. I had to.
- You got us a dog?
- Yeah, I did.
- Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
- So, honey, I've gotta
tell you something, okay?
These rescue dogs have had
some tough situations.
And a lot of them take on
the personality of their owners.
- This dog--
- Mm-hm.
- Was owned by rapper Ice-T.
All right, little buddy,
come on out.
Aww.
[gasps]
Oh, hello, my little darling.
Oh!
- Man, [bleep] you.
You, thuck my [bleep].
Thith house ain't [bleep].
- Okay, buddy, take it easy.
- A little testy.
- [bleep] you, [bleep].
- Nothin' ever been eathy
for me in my life.
Now, hook me up with a treat.
- You want a treat, buddy?
- You want a treat?
- Is that what you want?
Here we go, sweetie. Here we go.
- Mm, yeah, that's a tathty-ass
treat right there.
- Now give me the whole bag.
- Okay, one treat is enough.
- Bitch, was I talking to you?
Give me the whole bag of treats
'cause I'm a treat killer
and a mother [bleep] handful.
- Somebody's grumpy today.
- Grumpy-wumpy.
- Lay my ass right up
on this comfortable-ass thofa.
- [laughs]
- I'm gonna sleep on this bitch
too, as a matter of fact.
And you know what,
mother [bleep] and bitch?
I'm gonna pith
and [bip] up here too.
- No! Oh, no! No, no, no!
- [bleep] you, man.
- Raise your hand at me.
- Okay, um, I've got something
for you, little guy.
Huh? Huh? You wanna play fetch?
You wanna play fetch?
You like fetch, huh?
- Get that ball.
- [bleep] you!
- Both y'all condescending
mother [bleep]
I ain't your entertainment,
bitch.
So [bleep] you!
- Oh!
- Get the door, okay?
- Well, hello. Who is this?
- Come on, Coco, don't worry
about these mother [bleep].
That'th my bitch Coco.
Oh, I forgot to tell y'all,
she's gonna be living here too.
- Wow, okay, you got
your little friend here.
- Yeah...
- Yeah, well you can...
- She can play here
for a while, sure.
- Puppy play date.
- Yeah.
- Play date?
We gonna have a [bleep] date.
That's what we gonna have,
bitch.
Come here, bitch.
[sniffing]
- Oh, are you...
- Okay, he's doing that.
- Oh, no, don't do that.
- Yeah, that's my shih tzu.
- Oh, dear.
Get the [bleep] out of here.
It's about to get graphic
in this bitch!
- Oh boy.
- How come you don't do that
with me?
- Honey, I told you.
- He does it.
- I just want to keep
this area clean.